on nous donne différents noms
elle nous prenons différentes formes
nous apporte en émerveillement
espoirs
nous apportons jouarre
nous sommes le marchand de sable et la
fée des dents nous sommes le lapin de
pâques et le père noël
et nos pouvoirs sont plus grands
que vous ne pouvez l'imaginer
notre mission est de protéger les
enfants du monde entier
parce que tant qu'ils croiront anneaux
nous ferons tout pour veiller sur eux
seraient est terminée
la peur va enfin régner sur le monde
jamais la menace n'a été si grande
alors nous nous battrons
des fois il révèle les filles et pas de
quartier
alors tu veux faire la course avec un
lapin
m
en mai est prête
tous deux non
attaché ou ya pas de ceinture c'était
juste expression
les mots comme ça
les marques présentes et cinq légendes